bonjour à toutes et à tous bienvenue
dans ce nouveau numéro de skins hague
un numéro dans lequel nous allons vous
présenter les douze maires et élus ou
réélus à saint quentin en yvelines
nous aborderons les priorités pour leur
commune et pour leurs délégations sur la
communauté d'agglomération les
programmes entre emploi transition
écologique et cadre de vie
on fait le point ce fait partie
[Musique]
cinq communes ont accueilli un nouveau
maire lors des dernières élections
municipales comme ici à la verrière
nouveau maire nouveaux projets à
commencer par l'éducation tablettes
tactiles et tableaux numériques dans
toutes les écoles et soutien scolaire
gratuit pour tous
la sécurité ensuite dans chacun des
quartiers renforcement de la police
municipale les médiateurs de terrain
enfin l'amélioration du cadre de vie
dynamisme propreté et embellissement
[Musique]
sur le territoire nicolas david est en
charge de l'emploi et de l'insertion
professionnelle ça passe par des
événements ce qui emploie une fois par
an au vélodrome avec énormément d'offres
d'emploi
[Musique]
pour va essayer d'améliorer vraiment
l'alternance en donnant un petit coup de
main aux entreprises qui recruteront un
alternat et puis il ya quelque chose qui
me tient beaucoup à coeur c'est le
mentorat pour que un jeune saint
quentinois puisse être coaché par un
salarié saint quentinois pour ouvrir le
réseau tour transmettre son savoir faire
dans la rédaction de cv notamment
nouveau maire également attrapant la
personne d'ali rabais là encore priorité
à l'éducation avec l'instauration de la
semaine des quatre jours des activités
ludo-éducatives facultative et gratuite
le mercredi matin
soutien scolaire gratuit pour tous
baisse des tarifs de cantine et
d'activités extrascolaires deuxième
point la sécurité plus de patrouille de
police doublement des effectifs de la
police municipale et déploiement des
équipes de médiation et de prévention
enfin le cadre de vie plus de propreté
avec l'implication des habitants des
bailleurs et la création d'une brigade
environnement côté territoire ali rabais
est en charge de l'économie sociale et
solidaire
nous avons à saint-quentin-en-yvelines
de très nombreuses structures de
l'économie sociale et solidaire
une des priorités avec le service
développement économique de
l'agglomération de saint quentin ce sera
de relancer tous ces acteurs de mesurer
leurs compétences leur domaine d
expertise les secteurs sur lesquels ils
interviennent pour pouvoir les réunir et
leur proposer une stratégie de
développement de l'économie sociale et
solidaire inventer des nouveaux outils
de financement par exemple
d'accompagnement de leur développement
qui leur permettent de se déployer sur
notre territoire de façon harmonieuse
complémentaires pour notamment créer des
emplois le ss et le secteur qui crée le
plus d'emplois et notamment d'emplois
durables
[Musique]
aux clayes-sous-bois philippe guez
ancien adjoint et désormais à la tête de
la commune une commune
intergénérationnel avec la création
d'une maison pluridisciplinaire de santé
une maison ou de la famille et une
résidence pour seniors une politique
tournée vers la transition écologique
circulations douces et un permis de
planter dans l'espace public
l'élu il encourage la participation
citoyenne avec la création de conseils
municipaux pour les enfants et les
jeunes
côté territoire philippe dit guen reste
délégué à l'enseignement supérieur il ya
déjà un projet que nous avions engagés
lors du lors du précédent mandat un
projet de longue haleine qui est une
extension de l'université de saint
quentin avec notamment tout un tout un
pôle haut niveau au niveau de la de la
médecine
[Musique]
nous avons aussi d'aider objectif
d'attirer sur le territoire de nouvelles
écoles
au niveau de l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines et bien entendu il y
à faire en sorte que l'université de
saint quentin en yvelines du psq prenne
toute sa place dans le cadre de
l'intégration de paris-saclay direction
villepreux avec un nouveau maire engagé
vers la transition écologique et le
cadre de vie mais aussi vers la
participation citoyenne et la démocratie
locale avec la création d'un conseil de
la vie locale avec divers comités pour
les aînés pour la jeunesse pour les
associations et un accompagnement
renforcé des acteurs économiques et
sociaux côté délégation territoriale
jean baptiste à monique oeuvre sera aux
transports et aux mobilités durables
aujourd'hui il ya plusieurs projets qui
seront apportées par l'agglomération de
saint quentin et notamment des projets
qui étaient déjà dans les tuyaux et des
nouveaux projets
[Musique]
nouveau projet je pense notamment au
déploiement des trottinettes électriques
qui m a pourtant il va falloir qu'on
avance sur les différents contrats et
les pôles l'épaule de garer mobilité ou
là y avoir un sujet on anime 18 sur
laquelle il faut qu'on avance mais aussi
le schéma des pistes cyclables
le plan de déplacement inter entreprises
la mise en concurrence du réseau de bus
la future agence de la mobilité des
saint quentin en yvelines et les
navettes suspendu et autonome un nouveau
maire aussi à montigny le bretonneux
avec un gros chantier la réhabilitation
du centre-ville plus accueillant moins
minéral avec plus d espace pour les
piétons les cyclistes et les terrasses
de café
un projet auquel seront associés les
habitants là encore la sécurité du
quotidien est un point important du
programme tout comme la transition
écologique avec un projet d'alimentation
bio et local pour les cantines à
l'échelle de l'agglomération
autre sujet phare la préparation des
jo-2000 24 en concertation avec les
habitants
l'édile poursuit le thème de
l'aménagement et de l'urbanisme jusque
dans sa délégation saint-quentinoise
l'arrivée la ligne 18 à guyancourt la
zone des bécanes le quartier des bécanes
sur le
derrière nous avons enfouissement de la
nationale dissocia trappe et bien
d'autres sujets
[Musique]
je pense qu'il y a plusieurs projets
très fort sur les douze communes face à
quentin en yvelines et bien sûr j'aurai
à coeur de tous les accompagner à
l'ecoute en étant à l'écouté bien sûr
des maires de chacune des communes cette
commune nouvelle norme est réélu et tout
d'abord françois morton à guyancourt
avec un programme axé sur la solidarité
auprès des personnes âgées et des plus
vulnérables mais aussi tournée vers
l'éducation la transition écologique et
la démocratie locale sur l'agglomération
trois thématiques fortes
la politique de la ville la santé et la
solidarité la santé elle est évidemment
au coeur des préoccupations alors des
français et donc plus particulièrement
des saint quentinois et d'aiguillon
courtois et nous avons effectivement
tout un certain nombre d'actions qu'il
va falloir renforcer on a vu à quel
point cette problématique de la santé
elle était majeure durant la période
écoulée comment un habitant de saint
quentin en yvelines peuvent facilement
trouver un médecin par exemple tout
simplement qu'ils soient généralistes
qu'ils soient spécialistes et on sait
que sur certains secteurs y compris de
la ville nouvelle
ça peut être un vrai un vrai problème
françois martou souhaite stabiliser
l'offre médicale et développer les
meilleures conditions d'accueil des
médecins sur le territoire à magny les
hameaux
bertrand ou lyon poursuit sa politique
de transition écologique avec notamment
la diminution des consommations
d'énergie plus d'énergie renouvelable
plus de biodiversité plus de nature dans
les cours d'école diminution du
plastique et lutte contre les îlots de
chaleur
côté transport plus de vélos et
l'autopartage autre axe la solidarité
envers les plus fragiles les seniors et
les familles avec la participation
accrue des habitants dans les idées et
les actions pour le territoire saint
quentinois bertrand ue souhaite
accentuer l'agriculture et
l'alimentation locale
par exemple en ce moment
nous sommes en train de finaliser la
surveillance de l'ensemble du foncier
disponible pour l'agriculture sur la
commune
c'est un élément important pour pouvoir
nous assurer la pérennité d'une présence
agricole sur sur l'agglomération autres
en jeune la diversification de l'offre
agricole
on a aujourd'hui beaucoup de céréales
sur l'agglomération sur les terrains de
l'agglomération il faut qu'on puisse se
diversifier pour trouver du maraîchage
trouver du verger trouvé de l'élevage
pour pouvoir favoriser donc forcément
l'approvisionnement des saint quentinois
en produits locaux et impulser les liens
entre producteurs commerçants et
habitants
côté espaces verts l'élu souhaite que la
nature riche sur le territoire puissent
vivre en ville et être ainsi protectrice
face au réchauffement climatique
[Musique]
environnement toujours avec la mère de
plaisir joséphine coleman ce verger
souhaite conserver et développer les 54
% des espaces verts de la commune sport
libre en plein air au parc des quatre
saisons
un parc pour les familles près de la
mare au sol plus de nature au quartier
du vélib ou le déménagement de l'hôpital
charcot devrait aussi libéré 20 hectares
qui seront aménagés entre espaces verts
et urbanisme trail ou d'errer dans la
ville 24 km de pistes cyclables
devraient voir le jour sur
l'agglomération l'élu aura la
responsabilité de l'environnement on a
d'énormes pépite en sur saint quentin en
yvelines
[Musique]
beaucoup de travaux ont déjà été faits
dans le cadre de plusieurs schémas que
ce soit au niveau de l'air au niveau
également du développement immobilier
mais il vaut billiers dans le respect
justement des espaces verts et puis nous
avons toute une série de deux projets
déjà en cours sur des schémas puisque
mes prédécesseurs avaient déjà bien
enclenché la machine un effort de
pédagogie sera dispensée auprès des
populations afin de rassembler les saint
quentinois sur chacun des projets des
préoccupations environnementales
identique à coignières ici didier
fischer souhaite racheter des terres
afin d'y installer des maraîchers pour
favoriser les circuits courts
autre chantier la réhabilitation du
patrimoine et en premier lieu le
classement de l'église près de la mairie
au monument historique ainsi que la
protection du village et la rénovation
du groupe scolaire bouvet côté
agglomération place au commerce le
commerce sur l'agglomération
c'est à peu près mille commerçants sur
l'agglomération
c'est un chiffre d'affaires qui est très
important à 1,2 milliard deux cents
millions d'euros à peu près en à 193 194
de grandes surfaces
[Musique]
la plupart de ces zones d'activités sont
des zones vieillissante des zones qui
nécessitent évidemment aujourd'hui des
interventions importantes
une restructuration probablement cela
d'autant plus qu'on est confronté en
fait un changement des modes de
consommation
et ça ça va faire partie des cinq six
ans qui viennent
je dirais à appropriée en quelque sorte
le commerce aux nouveaux modes de
consommation aujourd'hui parce que ça
nécessite évidemment de repenser notre
équilibre aujourd'hui commerciales sur
l'ensemble de l'agglomération
[Musique]
à maurepas place au cadre de vie en
mouvement logement zone d'activités
paris-ouest transition écologique avec
la plantation de 500 arbres et le
bien-être animal mais aussi la
rénovation du centre ville une ville
pour toutes les générations et une
démocratie locale renforcée par des
ateliers participatifs côté
agglomération grégory gary astier est
désormais en charge de l'habitat avec
des enjeux forts à travers le plan local
de l'habitat avec l'objectif c'est de
rééquilibrer l'offre sociale sur le
territoire
[Musique]
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines compte à peu près 34 % de
logements sociaux que quatre villes sur
l'agglomération ne remplissent pas leurs
obligations malgré tout d'autres
collectivités ont beaucoup de logements
sociaux également l'idée c'est de
rééquilibrer pour avoir justement
permettre à nos habitants de trouver une
offre de logements adaptés logements
sociaux logements intermédiaires
accession à la propriété résidences
services seniors logements étudiants ou
pour jeunes actifs mais aussi la
rénovation urbaine pour les quartiers
politique de la ville à voisins le
bretonneux alexandra rosetti entame son
deuxième mandat avec plusieurs chantiers
l'éco quartier de la zac de la remise la
création d'une vraie salle des fêtes est
un cimetière ainsi que la mise en place
d'une navette à la disposition des aînés
pour leur déplacement sur
l'agglomération l'édile troque sa
délégation de l'aménagement du
territoire pour celle du développement
économique
nous avons voté un plan de relance au
mois de juin de 2 millions d'euros pour
aider justement les entreprises les
particuliers et les tpe pme qui seraient
en difficulté
[Musique]
tout l'enjeu pour nous c'est de
continuer bien sûr à les soutenir
et puis également d'accueillir
éventuellement nouvelles entreprises en
mettant en valeur tous les atouts de 50
en anglais tout en s'adaptant aux
nouveaux besoins des professionnels
les espaces de travail faire plus de
cover king plus d espace de coworking
peut-être voit la fin il faut qu' il
faut que saint-quentin s'adapte à son
nous verrons ce nouvel environnement à
ce qui a émergé pendant sept ans dans
cette crise à elancourt de grands
projets se dessinent le réaménagement du
pont de lavilledieu l'aménagement de la
piscine de la colline d'elancourt en vue
des jo 2000 24 pour l'épreuve de vtt et
enfin le développement d'un projet de
loisir en lien avec lille de loisirs
côté sécurité la création du
commissariat du futur un projet qui
résonnera sur l'ensemble du territoire
jean michel fourgous est également à la
tête de l'agglomération
le président anticipe dès maintenant les
retombées de la crise sanitaire ya une
bonne synergie
et douze communes ont la puissance
ils ont très bien agi pendant la crise
ensemble
[Musique]
basque lur il ya une crise économique
devant nous c'est pour y répondre
l'agglomération saint-quentinoise est
soutenue par ses deux principaux
partenaires le département et la région
et nous on va augmenter l'employabilité
et des jeunes qui vont avoir plus de mal
à trouver du travail à fin septembre que
d'habitude et ainsi que l'augmentation
des chômeurs les gens déjà expérimenté
donc on essaie de trouver bien sûr des
des modes d'accompagnement le tout en
partenariat avec les entreprises
partenaires essentiels de
l'agglomération
celle ci poursuit le développement de
son attractivité son université est
classé 14e l'établissement au monde au
classement de shanghai de grands
événements sont à venir avec le
déroulement de plusieurs épreuves des
géo 2024 elle se veut aussi terre
d'innovation notamment dans les
transports
grâce au véhicule et navettes autonome à
venir voir que tous les élus vont quand
même à peu près dans le même sens en
respectant le sens subtil gauche et
droite
oui ya un climat de confiance qui
participent à la réussite de sa panda
c'est indiscutable je bouge plutôt un
président heureux ce qui m'a aidé c'est
terminé n'oubliez pas d'appliquer les
mesures barrières masque lavage des
mains distance
à très bientôt pour de nouvelles
aventures saint-quentinoise ciao
[Musique]